[Music]
this movie
[Applause]
[Music]
sucks before seeing Exorcist believer I
thought that the worst movie ever made
is a movie by Chris marker a French
essayist film called s solle which when
I was 12 years old made me want to bash
my head against a wall it was so
boring second to SLE is Southside with
you the story came out six seven years
ago of Brock and Michelle Obama's love
affair now just slightly below maybe
even above Southside with you is the new
Exorcist one of the worst films I have
ever seen in my life the
movie is not scary the movie is not
interesting the movie isn't even
coherent as a movie about an exorcism
anything good about The Exorcist the
original movie any and every single
thing good about that movie was either
taken out or inverted in this new movie
it started out for the
first 10 seconds pretty good because
it's started out in pora Prince Haiti in
the voodoo capital of the world with
what looked like a voodoo incantation
around a baby it's usually not a good
sign when the voodoo witches start doing
spells and incantations around your kids
so I thought okay that's right they cast
this weird spell and now the demons are
all around there and and we're going to
find out how terrible this was
until the woman describes the
incantation as being a beautiful
blessing this woman today at the market
who gave me the most beautiful blessing
of protection for Angela so even now you
think okay well she thinks it's a
blessing of protection but I know
watching The Exorcist that that's going
to cause some Demon stuff but as the
movie goes on you can't figure it out it
does the filmmaker know that this was
weird demon stuff does the filmmaker
think this actually was a blessing of
protection does the filmmaker really
know what this is all about and we get
the answer pretty quickly which is that
no the first movie is a Christian movie
it's got all sorts of sacriligious and
blasphemous sayings your mother sucks
and Hell the kind of things you might
hear in an actual exorcism but the
Exorcist is Christian there are demons
there are Catholic
priests and the priests cast out the
demons the priests standing in for the
person of Christ defeat the
Devil in this movie they go to pains at
every single stage to say this is not a
Catholic thing this is not a Christian
thing we're not pleased don't ever
accuse any of us of being Christian that
this is just about demons exorcism is a
ritual every culture every religion they
all use different methods it's going to
take all of them I've grown up with a
fascination of religions of all sorts
and this was an opportunity to explore
possession
through a variety of perspectives
possession oppression pagans and wicens
we'll talk about energy attacks a lot of
focus on
demons blatty the deeply Catholic author
of The Exorcist must be rolling over in
his grave what this reveals from the
first part is not only do the filmmakers
of this new movie not understand the
source material The Exorcist they they
don't understand the
church and therefore they don't
understand demons they don't understand
anything about this the filmmakers here
have the same attitude toward
Christianity that the ancient Roman
pagans did that pagans always have which
is they at best will say oh Christianity
is fine you can have your God and we're
going to have our gods and there going
to be a lot of gods that everybody can
worship Christianity does not allow for
lots of other gods that people can
worship Christianity is an exclusive
religion Christianity says there is one
God it's the beginning of the Creed I
believe in one God if Christianity is
true if the priest has any ability to
cast out the demons then all those other
false religions can't really cast out
demons in fact this is the scene when
the Pharisees are accusing Christ of uh
being a bad fellow they say well you're
casting out demons by the devil and
Christ says the devil is casting out the
devil A house divided against itself
cannot stand Shan
youan either Christianity is true and
all the other religions are false or
Christianity is false and the entire
world that The Exorcist takes place in
doesn't make any sense because the
Christian view of all those Pagan
rituals to cast out demons is that they
are in fact invoking demons that's the
only way so they don't from the very
beginning they don't really get it but
but there's this tension in the movie
where you say okay well the Ellen
Burston character the mom from the first
Exorcist movie when she goes on and she
opens up and she says oh it's not a
Catholic thing it's not a it's whatever
you know we can all do zarrian and
pagans whatever it's not just in one
location or one religion or one culture
it's Universal are they making fun of
her so in the movie spoiler alert some
girls a couple of girls get possessed by
demons and I'm skipping over like most
of the plot here because the plot is
just terrible and boring and I was
checking my watch the whole time anyway
they get they get possessed by some
demons and one of the dads goes up and
finds Ellen Burston and says hey can you
help get the demons out of my daughter
and Ellen Burston goes in to try to cast
the demons out and you think oh good
grief they made that now The Exorcist is
a woman how woke is this thing going to
get and and then Ellen Burston in one of
her monologues she says well I was
prevented from doing this by the
patriarchy but I'm I'm a minister and I
can and it's just all this woke feminist
clap trap but then the thing that gives
you a little hope for the movie is she
goes in and she tries to cast out the
demons and it doesn't go very well for
her
don't be
scared we've met before Oh open your
eyes so this is probably the scariest
and goriest part of the whole movie and
it's still pretty cheesy but at least
here you think okay Ellen Buren's
character failed at doing the exorcism
so maybe all of this setup about how
look man we can all cast out demons you
know just using the Vibes and you know
women can do it and Priests aren't a
thing and nothing really matters man we
we're just focused on the demons to see
ourselves in this scenario is a huge
thing it's going to open the story up
it's a way to bring it into the present
and that's why representation is so
important it's all about me at this
point you think oh maybe that was all Bs
and now we're going to have the priest
come in and save the day but from the
beginning they're starting to cast these
priests as weak and feckless and
confused there's a scene in which a
priest is convinced he should perform an
exorcism but the preets and the higher
ups all around him they say well we I
don't know if we can do this we can't
risk doing an exorcism this is
again an elementary mistake that had the
filmmakers taken any time to investigate
what exorcisms actually are or what you
know Christianity the faith that
constitutes the worldview of this entire
movie and Cinematic Universe what they
actually believe how the church operates
they they could have avoided making
these silly mistakes when when the prets
come in or whoever the higher-ups are
and they say father this is very very
dangerous it's dangerous for you this is
a very dangerous situation dangerous for
you father dangerous for the Catholic
Church dangerous for you to perform an
exorcism why has God not conquered the
devil has Christ not cast out the demons
what is it it's not dangerous the danger
for a priest is that the priest might
sin that's a danger for all of us but if
you are in a state of grace if you have
taken on the holy mantle of God and
availed yourself of the sacraments and
especially if you you've taken holy
orders and you're a holy priest you
don't have to fear the devil no no
priest is going to go and Afraid Of The
Devil not with that kind of survi fear
and then they go on they say this is
very dangerous for the Catholic Church
how is it dangerous for the Catholic
church it's one of the Catholic Church's
jobs is to perform exorcisms what are
you talking about as though exorcisms
are never performed that's a
misconception that a lot of people have
in popular life that's just not true
there are many many exorcists all around
every state every country every World
there exorcists everywhere the church
performs exorcisms regularly there's not
a demon hiding under every Rock but
exorcisms are required in fact by the
way every time you baptize a baby in the
in the traditional R of the Catholic
Church three exorcisms are performed
exorcism is not some weird exotic thing
that hasn't been practiced for thousand
years so there's no risk to the church
it was just another way to paint the
church as being weak and feckless which
is one thing if you're going to do it
based on facts plent there have been
plenty of scandals in the church if you
wanted to do it based on facts this was
just based on a complete
misunderstanding they wanted to make
sure when they were portraying different
communities of faith that they were
portraying it accurately so then we get
into the exorcism these people they're
going to do the exorcism anyway and
there's this woman oh this whole this
whole story line this woman who was
going to become a nun and then she
violates her vow of celibacy and her
call to Chastity she has sex with a man
she gets impregnated and she has an
abortion which is very unlikely it's
very unlikely that if you're the sort of
person who is going to become a nun that
you are the sort of person who uh is
going to have sex with a man it's
unlikely it could happen but it's
unlikely and it's very very unlikely if
you're the kind of person who takes life
and moral so seriously that you're
considering entering into religious life
it's very very unlikely that you're
going to kill a baby through abortion
but anyway that was the that was the
setup for her character and then this
woman decides to take it upon herself to
perform the exorcism and that would be
bad enough but then they bring in all
these other people like they there's
this Witch Doctor kind of woman who's
filling up a bath with rose pedals or
something this is a reminder by the way
sometimes religious people get a bad rap
for being superstitious religious people
are the least superstitious people on
earth I am a little stitious because
religious people while we believe in
metaphysical things and we have
intuitions about the world that go
beyond the material world we subject
them to the the rigor of logic if you
don't do that if you don't pursue say uh
theology which is Faith seeking
understanding you know applying logic
and and reason to it then you're going
to end up doing weird hippie Voodoo
stuff like rose pedals in a bath and
blow weird smoke at and engaging in all
these superstitious rituals that Pagan
religions have done since time
immemorial uh that that's the real
Superstition so they do this they've got
all sorts of other people trying to
perform these exorcisms and they don't
work has all this hippie set up in
ironic and it's really going to return
to the roots of this movie and the faith
and the meaning of a real exorcism and
the priest walks in the priest says okay
I don't care that I didn't get the
approval of my Bishop I'm going to go in
and perform this excis anyway and it
starts out pretty well God play a trick
on
you the priest dies and now we got to
wait for the witch doctor and all these
other confused people to try to do
something this was the moment I think I
audibly said oh come on you know give me
a break the first Exorcist movie is
about how Christ conquers the demons the
of Christ compels you the power of
Christ compels you and in this you have
this explicit scene in which the demons
conquer Christ which just renders the
movie not believable you might not be
Christian you might not believe in
Christianity you might not even believe
that God exists the story presumes that
God exists the story is about exorcism
the story specifically is about the
Christian understanding of exorcism none
of this makes any sense don't forget we
have hold over characters from the first
Exorcist movie here this is in that
universe so you've just completely
destroyed the entire universe of the
movie and contradicted the religion that
forms the basis of the movie and reality
itself it's a it's a total inversion of
everything the resolution of it how do
they save any of the girls they end up
saving one of the girls by appealing to
the
girl's feelings for her mother I wanted
to talk to Mom the thing that helps to
bring her back is this scarf that is
from her mother the deepest reading of
this that one could have is that this is
an appeal to ancestor Spirits one of the
most basic elements of every Pagan cult
that has ever existed in the world
ancestral possession ancestral spirits
that visit you after death you would
look to ancestors you would look to
Spirits for guidance the fact that some
of them could be
malevolent is extraordinarily common an
even shallower uh possibility and I
think one always has to assume the most
shallow possibility in a film this in
coherent is that a physical object
really even devoid of spiritual import
just a thing that makes someone feel
kind of good is what brought her back a
story really that's about the power of
love in the face of spiritual obstacles
emotional obst all those things or that
Voodoo curse that could have started an
interesting movie actually turns out to
be a protecting prayer once again
totally inverting the whole point of The
Exorcist making the demons the good guys
basically
any of those reads on that resolution
are pathetic and totally devastating to
the entire Narrative of the movie and
then you get then you get maybe the
worst part of the movie you think that
you've already it couldn't possibly get
any worse if it got any worse it would
become Southside with you Amazing Story
complex um intelligent and Charming this
final monologue from the would be none
turned nurse turned not very successful
Exorcist Minister lady here's what she
says at all means what do you think evil
is I'll tell you what I think it is that
we're born in this world with Hope and
Dreams and a desire to be happy and the
devil has one wish make us give
up and maybe that's all God any God or
any good person really wants from us
just to keep going maybe that's all God
any God or any good person or whatever
you believe I don't care give me your
money you stupid clapping seals I don't
know we don't there's no meaning in this
film it's just oh spooky demons Give Me
Your Money what's it about I don't know
God or like some pagans or your family
or I don't know whatever we pick up the
story of Victor and his daughter Angela
a man who's raising his daughter alone
but there's also demons by the way which
I know it seems kind of weird but the
film is dealing with the vulnerability
of Parenthood with a child that's
dealing with possession there's not
going to be any context or explanation
for how demons are real spirituality is
a part of everything we do whether you
believe or not believe there's something
bigger than us this is truly a movie for
our times it's a movie where people
adopt the heresy of indifferentism the
belief that all religions are basically
the same which we know cannot be the
case because religions make different
and in fact contradictory claims but we
just and we know that we all know that
we just don't want to think about it
because that feels kind of judgy you
know it's kind of like judgy and
exclusive and you got to like pick
between one thing or another thing I
believe that's the way evil works is to
take you apart and to so division hey
man what's evil you know what I think
evil is I'll tell you what evil is evil
is the privation of the good there okay
we can move on now let's get into
something more interesting what's a more
interesting story that in the beginning
was the word and the Word was with God
and the Word was God and then the word
became flesh and dwelt Among Us he saw
Satan fall like lightning from heaven
and there was a war in heaven and a
third of the angels rebelled and
followed Satan down to the very pits of
hell and now the the Devil Himself prows
about the world seeking the ruin of
souls that's a line from one of the
prayers that was offhandedly mentioned
in the movie before they completely
undermined the prayer and there are
demons but there are also angels and
there's also a church on Earth with
power over the demons and there's
spiritual combat and there's Warfare and
it's specific and it's detailed and it's
interesting and you can follow the plot
at least or
hey
Mom
scarf rose
petals
woman
hak
[Music]
good
what's more interesting to you I think
the former is a little more coherent
something very very bad occurred to me
something not very good occurred to me
which is that I spent I spent hours of
my life precious hours that I will never
get back in this Fallen temporal World
watching this utter unbearable
tribe see you next
time
[Music]
[Applause]